welcome back to the iced coffee hour i
know you guys are gonna absolutely love
this episode because we have a lot of
pretty big drama going on we got a new
person to introduce to this whole
equation and a lot of exciting stuff i
know you're gonna love so let's get into
it oh right after of course you
subscribe you gotta subscribe it's
totally free it takes you just a split
second and as a thank you for doing that
here's a picture of a puppy
a puppy yeah a puppy like on the screen
like as a thank you for subscribing
there's a poppy right now on the screen
we're gonna go straight into some drama
guys i have an honest take right here
andrew and i were talking about before
this episode i don't know how well the
midweeks are working that's it i said it
i said it really yep that was her whole
plan is to do midweeks every week i know
but i don't know how well they're
working why is that because if you look
at the views that we're pulling right
now per episode it's a lot less than
before we were doing the midweeks
obviously when we initially did the
midweeks i think there was a lot of
excitement around them and so we saw the
views spike a lot then
but if you look over time overall the
channel's been on a little bit of a
decline i don't know if that's directly
related to the midweeks but i think we
would we would be idiots to not
acknowledge that there's something
happening so here are my thoughts the
midweeks are capped at probably 40 to 80
000 views depending on the subject and
how big of a deal it is like you getting
margin call jack that was the best thing
to happen to the channel i don't think
we should hold ourselves to doing one
midweek every week right we should wait
because if we force ourselves to create
content when there's nothing there guys
stay tuned there's a lot of content for
this one yeah we force ourselves to make
content where there's not any content
there i don't think we're doing the
viewers any justice and i think that
overall it's hurting the channel i could
agree with that part of me thinks the
decline on the sunday videos is due to
the guest i was going to say that that's
what i agree with the midweeks like um
that they will not do as many views as
probably like a guest video
but looking back and looking at the
amount of guests so going back to you i
agree i think we should do midweeks when
there's you know plenty of stuff to talk
about
but i think the decline on sunday views
is because of the guests as well and
we've had a lot of uh
repeat guests as well yeah i agree with
that i think those are very valid points
and i think the solution to this let me
know if you guys agree is to not uphold
ourselves to be doing one mid-week every
single week but to allow ourselves to do
one mid-week maybe every two to three
weeks when we have a lot of stuff to
talk about that we don't think
necessarily fit in a sunday episode
i don't know i think we need a schedule
that we stick to
uh it could be every other week and we
start with that i do agree that if
there's nothing to talk about there's no
reason to post an episode i agree so i'm
good with you because i think the other
week we didn't post to midweek and i'm
like jack i mean there's nothing and you
were out of town too but there's nothing
there's even that midweek prior to that
yeah we were really struggling remember
how long we sat here before we filmed
before we filmed guys just a little
behind the scenes we all think right
here we sit alone on our phones and
we're just constantly like researching
topics or just going in our head and
thinking like what can we talk about we
spend like 20 minutes before each
midweek each of us so wonderful
though
i don't remember how they did oh was
that that weight one yeah that was weird
one i believe yeah i thought they liked
it let me let me look right now
i thought they i thought that episode
did fairly well the episode did do
actually pretty well for us yeah 53k so
uh and it's a six i mean that episode
did better than
some of the other midweeks yes yeah
all right i mean i thought it did well
the thing is it's like the midweeks the
people who really want
the midweeks love the midweeks so i
think the people who watch really enjoy
it and but and then it's like you know
do we do we want to split off and maybe
do like just a just a us channel
no
i think holding it on the ice coffee
hour and i think doing a midweek when we
have content is just the the solution
here i don't think upholding ourselves
to one mid-week per week i i don't like
the idea okay of trying to force
conversation okay yeah i have another
solution alternatively yeah
we could do a mid-week every week
and even if the mid-week is like 30
minutes
we could post it on patreon
unlisted i actually don't think that's a
bad idea yeah
but i also don't potentially i don't
it's just an idea to think about oh you
don't want to put content behind a
paywall yeah yeah i kind of agree with
that like show the people but all the
good content like all the the business
interviews all the stuff that really
make the iced coffee or the iced coffee
are always will be free yeah on you know
on youtube that's just the like i think
and we really don't like it after the
fact i don't mind posting another
patreon but i don't want to use that as
a tool to like yo guys check out our
patreon unreleased oh no i don't know it
should be like that i should just i
think the people who are going to
support us on patreon they're probably
the people who watch all the midweeks
they're probably yeah but i i don't want
to
make those people then pay for episodes
that wouldn't be available here i just i
wouldn't feel good about that yeah i'd
rather like we continue what we're doing
here so like everything stays the same
and then do something extra okay for
that yeah you know what jack how about
this maybe we go down every other week
and if there's a week there's there's
truly nothing then we just skip it okay
i'm down that's it once every other week
yeah we should talk about some of the
comments that we did receive on that
last video with houston yeah those were
spicy i didn't think anything bad of it
of it and then i read the comments like
a few days in like which comments
because there's a lot yeah i remember
you you kind of brought something up to
me yeah i showed alex have you seen this
i was like was it this and he's like
wait no it was this and i'm like the
comments on the episode with houston are
there's a lot of hot takes there's a lot
a lot of hot takes now let me read some
of these comments and i think there's a
lot of context missing from this so are
these some of the top comments here's
the top comment uh there was a
disagreement where
uh houston was sitting there
and there was something missing on the
patreon i i asked jack if he was gonna
do it and he said no or jack didn't do
it i said well that you know you should
no i did it i asked i submitted the
questions to be asked but they only had
12 hours to get yeah instead of 20. and
then what happened was you went and you
gave me this look and that's what
frustrated me not necessarily like the
you know i mean but the the
dissatisfaction yeah
okay that was it and i said it should
have been done 24 hours
to get more time for the questions yeah
and then we left it up to houston
houston felt like that would fall on you
but i could see how i assumed it was
going on you without ever saying that or
ever i
the idea of patreon initially came up
i told you my main apprehension towards
it was that it would be something that
would immediately fall on me and i know
for a fact that that would be nothing
you would ever consider it basically
like i have no problem with this right
as long as we agreed to it but i didn't
necessarily want to agree to the to the
idea that you'd kind of chill out right
here and of course i'd bring the
questions i'd do all the the post
responding i would welcome everybody i'd
ask you know what i mean i i didn't like
the idea that i would just be assuming
all of that right but you do get a
significant portion of that yes like you
you don't get any more than i do
so
you know i also feel like i do bring a
lot to the table in terms of the
audience and the main channel and like
in terms of a funnel
everything that i've built up kind of
funnels down through this so i felt like
in terms of a split that that that's
pretty generous
okay i i agree i mean of course i would
be an idiot to not right to deny that i
think a lot of these comments think that
you don't get paid for that
for what the patreon patreon no no i
definitely i get paid for the patreon i
mean i'll i'll openly say it's 50 50.
it's even split my my main concern like
i said in the beginning when we
discussed the idea was that all of the
responsibility following me
and for you it's obviously worth your
time if you're like not doing anything
if you're not doing anything but for me
it's like if that's just another thing
that i have to like keep a mental note
of all the time and this is something
that i do multiple times per week right
i have to always respond to people on
patreon that which is you know a decent
amount of stuff and post and prepare for
podcast post the podcast early after all
that stuff right um it it starts getting
a little bit jumbled that's that's the
thing and then when you gave me the the
look of like hey man i'm so i'm sorry i
did 12 hours before and you gave me this
like dissatisfied look i was like oh my
god like this is what i knew it was
gonna happen i was gonna mess up one
time and then graham would look at me
unhappy and i'd be like you know what i
mean
that was my main
we run a very tight ship here things are
posted on time yeah uh they're never
late and we're we're one of the only
channels who's ever been consistent for
this long really yeah at least at least
my main channel for five years
over five years
yeah i don't know we haven't uploaded
i've never missed a sunday upload yeah
and i make sure that same with the
second channel and four years i think
it's like four years we've not missed a
single posting yeah ever yeah i remember
i had tonsillitis for an episode on the
second channel i was bedridden i was
like completely destroyed and i texted
graham and this is by the time i had
already assumed all responsibility or
all back end of this the second channel
i couldn't do it right i was like
destroyed and then graham's like all
right that's fine and he just took care
of it graham edited the entire video i
think he stayed up like really late to
bang it out and i was like wow this is
like yeah i really appreciate it that's
what it takes if you want to get good at
it you there's no excuses you just got
to get it done and take a lot of pride
in that never being late always
following through on that so things like
that i i and i lead by example it's
never something where i'm like oh jack
you're doing that and then i'll be the
one like falling behind like i'm always
i'm willing to do anything so if there's
something that falls behind i'll do it
and i saw a lot of comments saying yeah
like jack and graham it's inevitable
they're going oh yeah i saw those
comments
the thing is what people see on the
podcast this is generally where we're
trying to hype things up and make them
more exciting but they don't see like
the years i mean has it been three years
it's been more than over three years
i've been working with grandpa i've
lived with graham for nearly two you
know what i mean like he's one of my
best friends so of course i would i
would never leave graham and graham
would never leave you jack's gonna
officiate the wedding i'm gonna
appreciate their way yeah like it's it's
let's read some of these comments okay
i'm on jack's side here graham is too
consumed with making money off every
little thing graham is a slave to
youtube respect to jack for standing his
ground i don't know what that was in
regards to i think that's just a little
bit it's a pretty aggressive take i do
agree graham does have a fixation on
making money on every little thing we
know about that with the volvo we'll
talk about that a little bit later oh
man but i don't you know i think that's
just who you are i don't think it's like
a negative thing when it comes to
protecting your personal information you
seriously cannot be too careful you
might not think you have to be cautious
but once your personal information is
leaked it could be catastrophic and with
that said thankfully we have our sponsor
aura or is a one-stop shop that provides
identity theft protection fraud
monitoring it has a vpn service they
have password management and they also
have an anti-virus software all combined
into one easy to use app aura monitors
the dark web for your emails passwords
and social security numbers and sends
alert fast right to your phone and email
to protect your family and yourself from
identity theft at aura.com iced coffee
also linked down below in the
description seriously guys personal
information leaks are extremely scary
and it doesn't take a lot to protect
yourself from it plus or is offering a
two-week free trial when you sign up
with their link down below in the
description it really helps the podcast
and it would mean a lot once again guys
link down below in the description
protect yourself online thank you so
much aura and let's get
back to the podcast i respect jack so
much for wanting to keep his personal
life private instead of monetize it not
everything is about money or worth the
money this is in regards to bringing on
a tinder date yeah yeah
i don't disagree with that comment so
yeah i'll be completely upfront yeah
what upset me more was the patreon stuff
not the dating stuff because i
understand like this is all
light-hearted when we're talking about
tinder dates and everything and i was
pretty firm on my stance like i don't
want to bring on another tinder girl
here um and people i saw a lot of people
say like oh but you made a video walking
100 miles for a tinder date or you'll
tell stories no that's what i said
that's completely different than
actually bringing a girl on here and
like airing out our dialogue for an hour
and a half where i'm trying to be like
performative and flirty or whatever you
know i mean that's completely different
than me being able to like look back on
a story and tell a funny joke or
something that happened that ended you
know then this one luis rodriguez never
seen jack being upset stood his ground
and defended his point i appreciate that
they left it in the final cut i don't
think uh on some of the better weeks
even some of the conversations that we
have that are raw we don't cut like that
kind of stuff we'll just cut like if we
took any pauses or anything but yeah i
was honestly really nervous about that
episode going up because i was like god
like people are gonna think i'm super
lazy or that i'm like undeserving or
whatever you know what i mean yeah but i
was like you know what
it is what it is i said what i said and
i believed what i what i said i'm so
used to that already because every time
people leave a comment it's like like
how i mentioned earlier that i didn't do
the one text thing people assume that
because i i do that like i must just not
work at all like that people assume that
and they always comment like like oh
alex is so ungrateful i'm like i guess
sorry
those are my alt accounts
okay now and then last one don't work
for free jack get what you deserve
y'all are both the faces of the channel
i think people forget that uh this this
one sums it up jack is not an employee
on the podcast he's his business partner
which is true you're not an employee and
uh you
i know you don't want to say exactly how
much you make but uh
i'm you get up you get a you get a i get
a good amount yeah i'm you're not making
any more than i'm making on yeah am i
not no i'm not yeah it's the exact same
i'm incredibly fortunate and blessed to
be in the position i'm in it took a lot
of hard work a lot of like like i mean
the creation of the podcast alone with
graham and i and going through the whole
like developing part we weren't making
any money and countless hours when i
didn't have employees and everything
yeah it was a lot of work but i'm very
fortunate and blessed to be in my
position and uh i'm excited to keep
going so i know you guys are doing some
stuff together
alex and i yeah oh the weight loss the
weight loss yeah i mean we've talked
about it a lot on midweek so we'll keep
it a little bit brief yeah let's keep it
short but we did do a weigh-in and this
was probably after what a month is it
about a month a month and a half maybe a
little bit over a month yeah yeah maybe
a month and a week right yeah and you
have lost a total of 16 and a half
pounds and you look slimmer i noticed
that i said that today yes thank you you
look good the pancakes are healthy yeah
the pants are sagging falling like crazy
yeah um yeah so just to keep it short i
mean it's been absolutely great and i
saw a comment that uh
scott somebody responded to me in the
last one and they said it's a
double-edged sword putting that out
there because either you know you lose
weight and you have this cool story yeah
or you become like nicocado avocado
like embrace it um i don't think it goes
that extreme i'm like i'm pretty open
enough to like if i fail i'm like like
all right guys like i failed i'm trying
to figure out another way to do it but
um i love to hear that but i just want
to say you're not going to fail i 1000
know i will not let this happen and i
know you on your own accord you will not
let this happen either like this is the
time it's actually going to happen i've
told myself there's no way i'm letting
this fail no way i'm committed to it and
uh
it's gonna be really exciting
and uh oh yeah jack and i are gonna i
don't know if we told you this we're
gonna go to the to the heart attack
grill yeah oh yeah you did great
we're going to go right when i'm like
right by there and we're going to do a
little skit so it'll be fun yeah yeah
can you always go in and like i guess
drink a little bit more water if you
need to be like 351 or something like
that yeah yeah you could but uh yeah so
stay tuned i'm proud of you you're
killing it
you really have been much easier to work
with than i assume beforehand you're
like super open to it i don't know if
that's a comment
assuming you'd be against it but i guess
i i just had like the um
these presuppositions that like
to get to the size that you're creating
out trying to say is as politely as
possible that you must be kind of a
stickler when it comes to certain things
or everything but that doesn't seem the
case to be the case at all like you're
extremely open you're extremely like
good and uh i'm really proud of you
and i'm like that's not to say that i'm
not gonna encounter difficulties along
the way
um but for sure i've always been
open-minded about things and the one
thing i told jack is uh this is my
biggest insecurity if i could conquer
this dude anything anything anything is
the sky's the limit so
awesome
what's your goal weight i don't really
have a goal weight um to me it's more
just like a overall lifestyle change but
obviously like you know when somebody's
like i gotta hit a million dollars
like saying i lost a hundred pounds like
at least a hundred pounds
yeah i don't have a goal weight per se
but definitely like i want to lose at
least 100 pounds it's crazy to think
that out of 100 pounds you're or you're
almost 20 percent of the way there like
you're almost one thing if you're done
people have been so nice when i post
about my weight loss when i post
anything about it it always gets the
most traction people love to see it and
um
yeah i've just i've not to plug but i've
shared a lot of stuff on instagram this
is actually not a blog like please don't
follow me on instagram but no go follow
him everybody go follow him no but
people love it and every time i weigh in
with jack it's cool that um i get to
post an update and i think that even if
i gain you know let's say i weigh in two
weeks later and i gained two pounds i
think that's a good story to share
because i don't think very few people
have a story where it's just like yeah
no no issues whatsoever and i hope that
happens but even if we if we get there
and i have a bad week or whatever i
don't mind hearing that i mean i'm
already going to be better than where i
was before so how's kelsey dealing with
it is she uh how supportive is she is
she
anybody that is super familiar yeah
she's good um she let jack throw
everything out of our pantry did
she's been eating what i eat um which
for those of you that don't know kelsey
weighs uh she just
got weighed she went to the doctor she
weighs 98 pounds oh wow and uh i think
she needs to eat more but um she was
definitely not eating as healthy like
beforehand like um i don't know how to
explain it's not like she was eating
obviously i had a problem maybe with
quantity uh but i think we both have a
problem with not like not eating
let's just say whole foods right like
like
obviously i cook but not you know not as
frequently as i do now and so her
adjusting to having
meals that are that are at home that
that are cooked more frequently than
before uh obviously she's liked it and
we have a deal going on where i'll cook
but she'll clean all the dishes so
beautiful
yeah so super supportive that's good i
don't know if you guys saw but faze clan
recently uh went public i saw that yeah
what do you guys think about that and as
soon as it went public i think it
dropped something like 30 percent yeah
no um i think we need to disclose what
exactly phase clan is do you wanna yeah
yeah so for those of you that don't know
face cleanse started off as like a
esports team they i think they played
call of duty and uh they went on to then
sign talent that includes streamers
gamers uh faze rug is a vlogger so at
this point they've just become almost
like talent management
um but they're very much in the gaming
space still um and they've done now i
think they also have like
uh celebrity investors now too i think
uh was that drake or no he was 100
thieves right
no no no but they have celebrity
investors in this and uh they went
public stock dropped 30
so what do you guys think about this are
you gonna invest in vase claim do you
see a potential future uh you know i'm
done with individual stocks as we all
know here uh but i do think they were
overvalued at one billion dollars and
one thing i'm extremely excited for is
the release of the financial statements
to actually see how much is this like
talent management company or whatever i
shouldn't call them that like the face
clan how much money are they making
because that's just been something
that's right
the thing is it could be a great
business because it's low overhead that
these guys could just be in their garage
playing taking sponsorships doing all
that stuff it could be a good business
but what are they at like 800 million
dollars yeah they were
it's so risky because you have to be
following these people they have to keep
up on trends there's so much i mean this
could be a business that's out in five
years from now like 20 years from now
people are really going to look back and
be like oh phase clan
maybe
i wouldn't put any money in it
personally
i couldn't do that they have to i feel
like they have to have more of a product
than just like merch and like brand
deals and like talent management maybe
what about like their own channel or
their own like you know service or
product that they can really sell like i
just don't know just to clarify i think
they have to do that if they want to be
worth almost a trillion dollars because
honestly they could stay private i'm
sure they're making bank yeah but they
could stay private they could grind away
keep their overhead low i feel like
going public also adds more
not overhead but regulation uh for
reporting and keeping it's a money grab
alex that's what it is why would you why
would you go rich i mean here's the
thing i think if you if you believe
you've kind of peaked a little bit and
you think
maybe it's downhill let me go public
then at least it's it's the investors
who take the risk and not me
right i mean if they were a growing
business
and they're that profitable and they
could reinvest it
exactly so i'm thinking maybe they they
see through there's an end to the
longevity
how long could they sustain maybe they
just burnt out they're like hey let's go
but that's what i think i think they're
they're at the end of an era and going
public is like the last thing to do i
think they did it late though because i
mean if they did this when spack ipos
were like going they were talking about
this for a while
yeah they were oh so it was probably a
huge long process yes yeah i feel like
they missed it i feel like if they did
this at the peak oh obviously
i also think back even when spack ipos
were like a huge deal faze was still
kind of teetering i feel like at the top
i think they kind of realized this they
wanted the cash grab i shouldn't say
cash grab but they wanted to make a lot
of money and that's exactly why they
appeared for like a a way to get out if
they needed it yeah but they all
definitely just got insanely rich
i mean i agree with you but then you
also have stocks like d-wack which are
trading at 31 a share now now for those
who don't know usually with a spac you
open up ten dollars a share and these
are special purpose acquisition vehicles
basically that uh
you'll raise money for the purpose of
then acquiring something else and when
they merge in really simple terms then
they'll become publicly traded uh so
it's it's an
easier way for companies to go public
through this back right now dwack which
is uh social media that what is it the
truth social media
yeah um
is an idea there's no product
we have nothing so it's trading at 30 a
share i don't know what the valuation of
that is um on an idea blows my mind but
uh like we all have ideas yeah yeah
remember big clout by the way
yeah what's what happened to that i
don't know wait what i think it did
what's big big clout was where
you could
invest cryptocurrency within their uh
bit clout coin or whatever based on how
popular a person is influencers yeah
exactly yeah and like some people were
worth way more if you got like one token
of mr beast obviously it's gonna be a
lot worth a lot more than like one token
of grant or something so graham could
could he put up part of his company no
like a gram token no so it's free so i
so they already have profiles on there
and that was a big deal because like
justin bieber is not a part of it but
justin bieber's on there and he could
claim his token if he wants to elon musk
was on there and his his token was
trading for like 30 000
and he could go and claim it and
eventually he could get a percentage of
what people invest and you could set it
so that like if people want to invest in
you you get like 10 of it
yeah
so
i mean to me it that that looking back i
mean it's very much like that that was
the point you couldn't withdraw any of
it like it's only within the platform so
people were putting money in the
platform with the expectation that maybe
one day it'll be worth something and
they could withdraw it i mean that was
like similar to vv when people were
buying nfts but you couldn't withdraw it
yeah yeah it'll be funny to look back at
all this like 20 years from now and
think like nfc is the stupidest thing in
the world like seriously people are
trading like nfts of this stuff for 30
grand like
i don't even now how do you not see that
as like a tulip thing like i believe
there could be a few it's good
but i believe there could be a few
looking back that maybe are you know the
original one maybe a crypto punk or
something like that maybe but i think
we'll look back at these it's so stupid
yeah i think the only ones that are
gonna have value aside from like the oh
i wanna have an og one peoples peoples
yeah but i think
well aside from those i think the only
ones that are going to have value are
the ones that actually provide value
yeah like to give you access to this i
agree with that and graham always brings
up an example of like i like nfts for
verification
right but what if if nfts are only used
for verification so one example it
brings is let's say you have a louis
vuitton bag and you have an nft tied to
that louis vuitton back well the nft
doesn't have any value it's the back the
nft is only providing verification so
what if somebody counterfeits a louis
vuitton bag to sell with that nft you're
essentially now selling a useless asset
with a fake verification and having the
real asset whatever's holding its value
yeah that's true
but here's the thing nobody's checking
nfts like you could have a fake louis
vuitton bag and no one's really let me
see the nft on the blockchain and make
sure it's like nobody's ever gonna you
so like fakes are still to do really
well yeah but i think it's just another
layer of just you know
yeah jack that rolex let me see your nft
on the blockchain
you know
so that's what i think i think just
it's like concert tickets i could see
that you know special events have an
energy so you could collect nfts for all
your because i know a lot of concert
goers save their tickets or they're like
i've been to x amount of accounts but
like but like when a what was it the 12
year olds who made 400 000 selling
whales i mean come on really who who
buys these things seriously
yeah and i know it's easy to say in
hindsight because when you're in the
moment on it's like oh wow these whales
are selling this could be the next big
thing but it's always i'm curious what
the next thing is going to be because i
feel like we've seen so many run-ups and
like nfts were a big part of that but
like what's the the next thing okay so
now we're gonna be taking a couple
questions from you guys first question
is from colin how is creator properties
doing decent uh i think it's a lot
different than what i expected going
into it um and just how many moving
parts there are but uh long term i'm
really looking forward to it and it's
it's been more challenging with this
market than i think
people were expecting going into it and
uh it seems across the board but overall
not only you know i applied and they
said i couldn't invest because you're
not accredited i can't invest i don't
even know what that means you're not
accredited you need to have a million oh
okay yeah yeah well for those that don't
know what it means it means you either
have to have a million dollar net worth
or two years of tax returns over two
hundred thousand dollars a year what if
you're married if your joint tax return
yeah is over two hundred thousand
dollars a year for two years you're fine
but being married alone is not enough
yeah unfortunately like i'm not
accredited but i'm but i'm married yeah
that's my only accreditation one more
question from me nom he's curious about
how you and andre think of video ideas
because you guys post like basically the
exact same videos all the time he
referenced the videos posted today you
posted the car market bubble just
collapsed and andre posted the car
market bubble is collapsing
did you see that
i saw that literally i saw both of them
i look at jack and i'm like yo check
this out andre i have not seen that
video yeah neither of us like the same
topics and the same titles yeah is there
a reason to this is josh
that's coincidence here's the thing we
made i made that video what was it like
two weeks ago yeah yeah and i was
waiting i got experian by the way to
sponsor that video experience like the
like the crib yeah so anyway um so i've
been going back and forth with
experience for like two weeks and i i
knew
this product that experian had would be
perfect for that video and there was so
much happening with the used car market
that i created that video two weeks ago
filmed it it was in review with experian
we just posted it today um that was just
wow yeah accidents that's crazy and we
took that thumbnail picture today too
yeah i thought it was really clean
thanks really good job that was out that
so that's alex so it was it was
my idea but okay
my idea but the thumbnail was alex so we
took the ford gt out we lined it up alex
got the shots and unfortunately the um
what do you call it in the back of the
car like the hydraulic like yeah that
holds the trunk open oh okay yes right
those are worn out in graham's car so we
he can't hold the hood open yeah so you
know what we had to do he had to go back
there hold it open we took a picture and
then he went and sat in front with the
front hood open and we had to like
combine this yeah combine the two
pictures yeah unfortunately the
hydraulic lift or whatever thing in the
back of the car
in extreme heat it doesn't hold it's
funny if it's below 80 degrees
it holds up just fine but 100 degrees
when it's out there for a few minutes
the thing just must be whatever fluids
in it or something i don't know whatever
i mean it shouldn't be doing that but
it's probably original anyway those are
probably so cheap anyway you could
probably get them for like under 50
bucks correct it's just a normal ford
part of some sort so yeah the thing is
there's not that many things to talk
about so when there's something when
there's like an event or something that
happens
everyone jumps on it because everyone is
like desperate for topics right now and
it's just like yo man you got any more
of this video ideas man i mean really
that's what it's like so when there's
something it's like of course everyone
is going to jump on it and then it
becomes who could jump on it first
so what i've begun to do this is my
little secret i'm not gonna tell
everything i
pre-planned videos
uh that i know there's a big event
coming up that day and then i'll say
multiple things that could happen so i
script everything
and then we pick and choose what ends up
happening so that i could get a fully
produced like really edited thought out
video with every scenario out there and
it's posted right after it happens so no
one yeah but it takes so much work
because i'm like what happens if they do
a 75 basis point rate hike what about a
100 uh point rate hike what about a 50
what what how do these differ and then i
could just write for all the scenarios
and if they don't go with any of those
then we have to be here and ready to
film stuff stuff out there
it's a grind
it's not a lot there's not not a lot
happening in the markets man is there
not there's nothing the market the thing
is the market's up five percent over the
last few weeks and that's bad for views
that's good for my portfolio it's good
for his portfolio bad for views though
yeah the more the market goes up you see
a direct uh correlation between market
going up views going down market goes
down views go up if you could have it
your way the market would just be just
crashing right
well the thing is you need extreme drops
like i would love a five percent drop in
a day talk about how the market's
crashing and then like 20 up in a day
um you know yeah that's what we need we
need extreme volatility for people to
watch youtube videos
one thing i want to discuss here i think
is kind of interesting is i went on
vacation
for nine days with minimal service
what do you think about that frustration
leave a bad taste in your mouth i was
frustrated there was a few texts that i
sent you that i never got a response
back to i knew you were out of town but
uh i guess it was really nothing that
urgent you let me know ahead of time
there's really nothing that i couldn't
you know what andrew stepped in a lot
oh my gosh andrew
as well yeah andrew's the new jack what
you know he's his own andrew okay andrew
you need a trucker hat you do you look
good yeah andrew's the new guy okay he's
doing a lot of work for me at the moment
he's editing this podcast doing the iced
coffee hour clips doing the sponsorships
on this editing the second channel doing
a lot of work that i'm kind of sourcing
through him
however i mean
still maintaining like quality control
but he's doing a great job yeah yeah
thank you
what is it really like working for jack
be blunt be honest give us the dirty
truth oh wait wait just to clarify not
only working for jack but you also live
with jack right yeah that's the more
difficult part i'd say
first of all contracting for jack yes
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah yeah i would say living with jack
and working with jack
combined together is a little bit
stressful sometimes just because trying
to play ping pong and do other stuff and
have fun and go out and do a bunch of
stuff while also trying to like hey he
knows i have a certain amount of work to
do today and i know he has a certain
work to that day you know what i mean
and then also trying to like not be like
oh you know this person knows what i
have to do and like we would certainly
be a lot more productive if we didn't
live with each other really i feel like
that would that would boost morale like
seeing you work and no i work so much
better when andrew's not really see
that's the problem graham he has to see
jack work
oh and jack doesn't work yeah that's it
and it will distract both of us like
we'll all of a sudden just start somehow
teleport to the ping-pong room boom
we're playing ping-pong and then there
goes 30 minutes so tell us some
negatives about the the working with
jack what is it what does he even say
anything
like what what you know is jack a good
boss do you think he's fair is he clear
on his instructions does does he let
things slide i'd say so i think he's i
think he's generally fair how can he
improve how about that what's something
that he could get better at um well
communication clearly is yeah i agree
that's yeah i think it's it's the kind
of the off and on like he is either kind
of really invested and really into one
thing and then like you know whether it
be business related or not uh but then
it's like you try to get a gauge and
you're like texting back and forth like
oh i have ideas for this or he has ideas
for this and we're bouncing it back and
then there's other like days where it's
like you know i text him about the
podcast he talks about anything um like
regarding work and he's just kind of
like oh you know i don't really want to
like he's just respond to that or
doesn't want to deal with it that day
and then i got in trouble one time for
texting him too much while he was on
vacation
no
what was it about well i think it was a
mix of personal and business
and i think that's kind of what mainly
frustrated me and it was also extremely
like long-winded it was probably like
like three boy i would love to see jack
respond to me like that i would
yeah jack doesn't respond to me either
it's okay yeah me too keep going yeah
other than that i mean there's really
not there's not nothing too bad um i
think we have a pretty good like
friendship slash like you know work home
balance um you know andrew we do have an
extra room here
that's true that's true i gotta get a
good deal on rent though so what's
what's how much is your rent could you
say yeah sure i paid 750 for my room
what would you offer for that uh bedroom
across the hall what would you what
would you offer are you trying to poach
his well yeah this is definitely not
happening why
i actually have another room
too okay let's skip this part of the
conversation no it could actually work
out really well hold on a second yeah
now overall andrew do you enjoy you
enjoy your work you enjoy working for me
you're bullish on it you're happy yes
yeah i i actually especially in the last
couple of months have really enjoyed
working a lot and really enjoyed just
being more involved i think getting more
involved in everything as well has just
made me a lot more like eager to do it
and yeah i've definitely enjoyed it a
lot and i would you know i do want to i
do want to grow more with you as well
jack and like kind of do it together you
know
well andrew gets paid
i think for the everything that he does
work on is all percentage based so as
long as we're growing he's growing with
me as well and i didn't want it to be
some fixed rate thing uh i want him to
have a visited interest in the good
performance and not only that but when
he was in initially he was initially
working for a fixed rate he was a great
worker so he's he's a little bit money
motivated but he's just a motivated
person in general and i'm extremely
happy and i've told you this a lot
before like to have you on the team you
do amazing amazing work don't know what
i would do without you so oh good yeah i
appreciate that yeah it's been good
working with you guys as well but now
if you wanted to you know get in this
bedroom here
we could maybe work out a deal where you
get the the bedroom you could work in
here if you need an office and uh you
know i'll teach you how to take care of
the fish tank when we're out of town
interesting yeah
andrew yeah trust me right now you do
not want that man you do not want that i
think you do though if we can get a ping
pong table here
then i could you know that that could be
something i can work with but ping pong
is pretty big for me as well as much as
for jag we'll talk
all right guys so that's andrew that was
one thing i wanted to do this episode
was introduce andrew he's a big part of
the team always been behind the the
curtains so i'm really happy to uh to
announce them to you guys and uh that's
it the vacation it was great thank you
for asking uh at nine days nearly no
service but we prepared pretty hard like
before the vacation getting everything
set up andrew did a great job grabbing
hold of the reins making sure everything
was running smoothly and the one point
that i wanted to make out of this whole
vacation thing is i would love to see
you in this position to be able to do
this if you wanted to if an opportunity
presents itself to you where you can
take some time off i've said it so many
times before i don't i don't want to go
into the rabbit hole but i just want to
say i know it's possible and i would
love for you to be able to to set up i
don't know man i love working i had such
a great day today
when he went to canada uh for the fourth
of july we had probably at that time we
were like the furthest ahead we've ever
yeah we had like three videos yeah
something crazy and he could have been
in canada for a whole week if you wanted
to and he chose to come back we did not
miss a single vid we did not follow
originally he had planned to miss like
one planned video on the fourth of july
on the fourth of july and um and he was
going to come back maybe later but no he
came back
pretty much before monday
i'm just weird jack i really enjoy
working i i know that you say that and i
know you think you enjoy work and i i
know you do enjoy work to a certain
extent but i think and i've said this
before i think you've been on the
biggest like dopamine detox for the
longest period of time because i know i
noticed and i mentioned this i've
mentioned this before i remember one
specific event arocs ping pong
tournament i went up to you we were
walking just downtown los angeles we
just got some ice cream we didn't do any
work the entire day we were hanging out
meeting a bunch of cool people playing
ping pong and i just said to you graham
you you just
doing it but that's taken a day off i'm
fine taking a day off taking a weekend i
love weekend trips but i like getting
back to work and i'm cool with that
nine days would be too much to drop and
do something if the opportunity presents
itself i think it's a great power and i
would love for you to have that and i i
love seeing you stoked like that i
really do yeah
day trips love day trips yeah cool yeah
all right let's grab dinner thank you
guys so much for watching this episode
of the iced coffee hour shout out to
everybody on patreon shout out if we
have any sponsors on this episode thank
you guys so much for watching check out
alex's
instagram
and get your free stock down below
my instagram thank you when you sign up
for
did you public.com your free stock this
time i honestly have not met why come on